i saw the internship i very much love
this film very funny
you guys do an amazing job you play
interns at google it's a very funny idea
i'm just curious of the two of you in
real life who is more tech savvy
well um i don't know that either one of
us are going to blow people away with
our
tech sappiness maybe maybe i would get
the slight edge only because i think you
were one of the last people to even get
a cell phone
that's julie had that a couple years ago
that's true
how late did you get a cell phone i only
had a cell phone i've had it for about
maybe just
just around three years and i'm glad
that i have it now so it's like uh
but i don't know that having cell phones
necessarily own qualifies is like tech
savvy you know i mean i could
say you were still using even like that
number that you would call when you were
a kid to get the time and temperature
you would call the operators i thought
it was important to plan my day
i had to make sure and when i hung up
i'm like is it still that time so i'd
have to call right back
do you remember that younger that was a
crazy thing to call you someone i
remember you would call that lady and
you'd find the time and you would you
back then
you had a job yes
but i'm curious why didn't you have a
phone for so long i mean how did you
last how long without a cell phone what
would you do
well i kind of felt like i didn't want
assistance i didn't have any assistance
either but i kind of felt like
people have the cell phone that's all
they were was on the cell phone and i
needed a break
and people call you like mainly agents
and stuff like that and i couldn't be
bothered with these animals i like their
spirit but at some point i needed a
great
but then i realized when i got it it was
good because you could stay and touch my
wife actually when my
my on father's day got it for me and so
then i had it but
it didn't bother me i like the old
system where they leave you a message
and then you would call them back at
some point
but i yeah i would i was also one of the
last people to have a computer
the first thing i had was like a an ipad
and i remember having an assistant that
i thought was like a genius because i
didn't even know you could
literally just google questions and
stuff so i'd ask this
assistant stuff and hit fire back with
like
you know first it was like easy stuff
like how many showings of this movie
this weekend then i'd try to stump them
with like what's the composition of air
and just
instantly get answers i was like this
guy shouldn't be my assistant he should
be working for the pentagon
you had no idea that he was listening to
you and just googling the answers
you think you're working for the
smartest person in the world
he's like you know yeah he's wasting his
time working with me
what's the uh now i have experienced i i
went to the google campus
it is and and you portray it in in the
movie
it's a world it's like out of a dr seuss
book i mean you portrayed it but it
really is a fantastical
world it really is a little bit to me it
was like being at club meadows sandals
because
it was like all-inclusive resort you
didn't pay for any of the food but yet
they had like
back handing or like you could play
volleyball they had nap pods there was
like swimming pools
you're never more than 150 feet away
from food which is a good thing it could
be a dangerous thing as well
and then they played an intramural sport
quidditch like the game from harry
potter
where you run away with the ball between
your legs and that felt like a high
injury risk of a sport to begin with
yes i think when we were there this was
like
i saw some guys go by on like a round
bicycle
that that and it's like these brainiacs
it's a special world they've created and
they were all drinking like a you know
fruit smoothies on a round bicycle that
went by and they're like
pretty good but we have a clip here from
the internship i don't know which scene
this is can you
this might be the interview is that was
this the interview and i think it could
be this is when owen and i first have to
uh have an interview to see if we can
get the gig to start at uh
at google and you guys have no business
working there at all
and uh this is your attempt to talk
yourselves into the internship well we
don't have a the the traditional resume
i'll put it that way yeah
let's go to this clip from the
internship um we're going to ask you a
few questions that some of our
candidates find a little bit odd let's
go
no judgment shoot you're shrunken down
to the size of nickels
and drop to the bottom of a blender what
do you do it's not so much
getting out of the blender it's what
happens next
you've got two nickel-sized men free in
the world
think of the possibilities i mean i i'm
top
maybe stick us in those submarines that
they put in people's bodies to fight
diseases
okay that's that's not a real thing the
submarines no wait a minute i thought we
were stuck in a blind
now we're saving lives what what
what what what what wait a minute we
were stuck in a blender
and now we're saving lives you guys led
us to this thank you